>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Robin Givhan: It is my
distinct pleasure to be able
to introduce Leland Melvin.
He is the definition
of a renaissance man.
[ Laughter ]
I am clearly a comedian.
He has been an NFL player for
the Detroit Lions, my hometown.
Just throwing that out there.
A NASA engineer.
And an astronaut.
He has also had his official NASA
portrait go viral because he posed
with his two beloved dogs.
He is also a writer.
And he is an engineer, who does not
just consider the science of space,
but the poetry and the
magnificence of it.
And he has written a memoir
of his extraordinary life --
Chasing Space: An Astronaut's Story
of Grit, Grace, and Second Chances.
He will also be signing
copies of his book
after his talk at two o'clock.
It is my great pleasure
to introduce Leland.
[ Applause ]
>> Leland Melvin: Thank you.
Thank you, Robin.
Thank you very much.
It is so great to be here.
It is my first National
Book Festival and I am,
I am really honored and I
am really inspired by some
of the other authors and just
what the Library of Congress
and the city are doing to especially
inspire our next generation
of explorers, like our little
ones like sitting over here.
And my title is the right stuff
is the never give up stuff
because I have had a lot of setbacks
throughout my life and journey
and I have always had
someone, at least one person.
I think this guy up here
in the front, Rudy King,
he was one of those people
that always had my back
and always believed in me.
And so I am going to
take you on this journey
that I have had over
my last 53 years.
NFL, getting to space, things
that I never would have imagined
that I would have done coming
from this small little town
of Lynchburg, Virginia.
So, let's go on the journey.
And I think this is working.
Houston we have a problem.
Okay. If you think
about May of 1961,
John F. Kennedy was petitioning
Congress to send a human being.
He said a man, the
man space program.
But I always change it to human
because when we say the language
of a man space program, when I go
into schools and I ask the kids,
who wants to be an astronaut
and say man space program,
none of the girls raise their hands.
So the language is so important.
So the human space program
he was petitioning Congress
for to send people to the moon
and back safely in May of 1961.
At the same time, Dr. Martin Luther
King Jr. was going to the south
to console the Freedom Riders
that were getting bombed.
We were having the most
technologically advanced thing
happening potentially in
the, in less than 10 years.
And we were not even be able
to get our civil rights
straight here in our country.
And I think about during
that same time in the 60's,
we had Gene Roddenberry with
Nichelle Nichols inspiring people
with Star Trek and the
Starship Enterprise.
And she was the first
African American woman
to play a leadership role
in the 60's on television
that was not a servant or a maid.
And I remember talking to
Nichelle about this and she said,
you know I was going to quit
the show early on and go back
and do you know do
some theater and dance.
And Gene held her resignation
over the weekend
for her to think about it.
She went to a NAACP meeting in Los
Angeles and bumped into someone
who said they were
her number one fan.
That number one fan was Dr. Martin
Luther King Jr. He was like,
oh my God it is Nichelle
Nichols [laughter].
And she saw his enthusiasm
for the show.
He even said, this is the only show
that I will let my kids stay up
and watch at night
because you are doing
with Star Trek what I am trying to
do with the Civil Rights Movement.
She tore up her resignation
and she stayed with the show.
And NASA hired Nichelle to
bring in the first women
and minorities as astronauts.
She was on a contract to do that.
Guy Bluford, Mae Jemison,
Sally Ride were all products
of this Gene Roddenberry, Nichelle
Nichols combination of inspiration.
Now, I watched a little Star Trek.
There was another guy who watched
Star Trek, who was Ronald McNair.
Ronald McNair was on the
Challenger that perished in 86.
But when he saw Star Trek, he
said to his brother, he said,
Carl if there are women
like that in space,
I want to go to space [laughter].
So, art imitating life,
life imitating art.
This was a way that we
were helping inspire
that next generation of explorers.
And in May.
In July of 1969 you know one small.
Back to that man thing.
One small step for a human,
one giant leap for humankind.
We were walking on the moon.
I was five years old.
And I remember seeing this
grainy picture on the television
and I will never forget after that,
kids were asking me hey do
you want to be an astronaut.
I am like, no [laughter].
I did not see someone
who was like me.
And they had these military
guys with buzz cuts.
And that was not me.
And I grew up in a small
town of Lynchburg, Virginia.
I lived on Pierce Street.
On Pierce Street there was a
doctor named Dr. Whirlwind Johnson,
who was the first African
American doctor
to integrate the local
hospital where I was born.
He was also.
Well there was.
There is me.
And then this is my sister and I
on Pierce Street wearing my
mother out okay [laughter].
We were always doing things
to wear her out, okay.
But here is Whirlwind Johnson
on the right in both pictures
and he was a tennis coach.
He was a doctor.
He trained Arthur Ash in Lynchburg.
Arthur lived in Richmond, would
come in the summers to Lynchburg,
five blocks from where I
lived training Arthur Ash.
My dad always talked about
Arthur Ash and his character
and his discipline
and his athleticism.
Brilliant man.
Althea Gibson similarly brilliant.
Won every tournament, every
tournament known to humankind.
I wanted to be Arthur Ash.
I still play tennis to this day
because of the influence
that he had on my life.
And I think about this
street, Pierce Street.
When I was writing this book,
Chasing Space, I went back
and did a little research about the
people that lived on Pierce Street
that helped change my life.
And I did not even
know it at the time.
There was a gentleman named Chauncey
Spencer, who was the son of poet,
Anne Spencer, from the Harlem
Renaissance, who lived four blocks
down the street from where I lived.
Chauncey was, wanted to be
an aviator as a young kid.
Went to the local [inaudible]
airport, Lynchburg Airport
and went to take flying lessons.
And they said we do not give
flying lessons to your kind.
He moved to Chicago to
take lessons at Love Field
from an African American
mechanic who could fly.
And eventually Chauncey
and his buddy got
in the Lincoln-Page Tail Dragger
airplane and flew to Washington.
And petitioned Harry S. Truman,
at the time who was a congressman,
to allow blacks to
fly in the military.
This is how the Tuskegee
Airmen were born.
Harry S. Truman raised
three million dollars
to allow black aviators to fly.
And so I think about Pierce Street.
This street of inspiration.
This street of Arthur Ash inspired
me to be a great tennis player.
And to have discipline and
have character and empathy.
And Chauncey Spencer one block away
from him getting me
setup to go to space.
And how many other.
We think about, you know,
Margot was here earlier talking
about Hidden Figures.
How many other figures have
been hidden from us for so long?
That we could inspire our
kids to believe and think
that they could do these things.
And literacy, you know
this conference is
about the American story.
And literacy is such a big
part of that American story.
I think last night they said
that 45 million people have less
than a fifth grade reading level.
And that means economic
disadvantages
because they cannot read.
And I think that all
of you who are here,
especially with your kids
helping read to them,
like my mother did
every night to me.
The Little Engine That Could,
I think I can, I think I can.
That was a mantra before I could
even read, I was thinking I can.
I think I can.
And then you know, Curious
George, you know [laughter].
The very curious adventurous
little guy
who would explore and
get in trouble.
And that was me.
So, I had I think I can belief that
I can get in trouble [laughter].
And I did many times.
But over the summers my parents
were middle school teachers,
we went on these camping trips.
My dad, when I asked
him for a skateboard,
he said we do not have
the money for it.
And this is when I
became an engineer.
He said, figure it out.
A piece of wood, a machine shop,
a paper route to get
the wheels and trucks.
I built a skateboard.
Something I wanted.
And I realized what
engineering was about.
It was not until my dad drove
this bread truck into our driveway
that I understood what
vision was about.
He was a language arts teacher.
He was not an engineer.
He was not a scientist.
But he over this summer convinced
me that we were not going
into the bread business because he
did a lot of different odd jobs.
This summer we converted this
bread truck, that said Merita Bread
and Rolls on the side,
into our camper.
When we rewired the
electrical system,
I became an electrical engineer.
When we built the bunk beds
that flipped down inside,
I was a mechanical engineer.
When we plumbed the propane
tank in the Coleman stove,
I was a chemical engineer.
But it was not until we
painted the side of the van
that I really saw this as our camper
because all I could see
was Merita Bread and Rolls.
And it even smelled like bread too.
So. But these were all things
setting me up for a life
as a scientist and as an engineer.
And when my mother gave me the
non-OSHA certified agent appropriate
chemistry set, this
is when I realized
that I could be a scientist.
And this is kind of
how it played out.
So, here you go son.
Make sure you read the
instructions, right?
Yeah right [laughter].
Yeah I read them, ha ha.
Yeah. And the next thing I
know I mixed this concoction
and blew up her living room.
Burned a hole in her carpet.
She had a big hand in my
development, you know.
She came from downtown
with that hand, you know.
I did not believe in corporal
punishment and I still do not.
But my brain was activated.
I knew that I could be a scientist.
And I ended up being a chemistry
major in college because of
that intervention, because
of that one intervention.
So the engineering, the
science, the music, the math,
all these things helped me believe
that I could do these things.
The I think I can.
The curiosity of Curious George were
all things that set me on that path.
Sports was very important.
I played football, a little
bit of football, you know.
And by the way, Robin, I
know Detroit is your home.
I am not a Lions fan because
they cut me [laughter].
So there is no allegiance
to Detroit anymore okay.
But growing up playing
football it was you know fun.
I had a good time.
Tennis was my love.
I had this one moment in my
life as a senior in high school.
Any football players in here?
Any high school players?
Any younger players?
Got a football player over here.
A wide receiver does what?
[Inaudible].
And does what?
Catches the ball, right?
I was a wide receiver
on a running team,
which means I block a lot, right?
My moment came.
We were down by a touchdown.
I am running down the sideline.
I am running.
The crowd is screaming.
You all scream.
I am running and running
[laughter], the crowd is screaming.
The ball is coming into my hands.
I am like going to catch
this ball and win the game.
By a show of hands, how many
of you think I caught the ball?
[Laughter].
By a show of hands, how many of
you think I dropped the ball?
By a show of hands, who
does not really care?
[Laughter].
Okay because none of, a lot of
you did not raise your hands.
I dropped the touchdown pass
in my hands in the end zone.
Homecoming game.
All my friends were there.
My family was there.
I felt like I was about this big.
Walked to the sideline.
My coach, Jimmy Green,
grabbed me by the facemask.
I was waiting to be like
ejected onto the bench.
And he said to me, I believe in you.
Go back out there and catch the
ball this time, okay [laughter].
So I am running down the
sideline the second time.
I am running.
The ball is coming.
The crowd is screaming.
I am running and running and
running and running and running.
I could read Spaulding
on the side of the ball.
I was so laser beam focused.
I caught the ball.
Unbeknownst to me, there was a
college scout from the University
of Richmond who was looking to see
if I could play football
at Richmond.
He walked out of the
stadium on the first drop.
He heard the crowd screaming
the second time and he came back
in the stadium and he looked over
and he saw me in the end zone
like you know [laughter].
That one catch resulted in a
180 thousand dollar scholarship
to the University of
Richmond [applause].
And the reason.
I think I can, right?
The reason he gave me
that opportunity is
because he said you did not give up.
The grit. The perseverance.
The grace.
All those things that I have talked
about in the book, he believed in me
because I did not give up.
And that is the message
that I have tried to put
to weave throughout the book is
that opportunities come to you,
but you have to be prepared
for that opportunity.
And having that one
person in your life.
All you need is one that has
your back and believes in you.
And I had many of those people.
But he was one of them.
Went to Richmond, football
scholarship, majored in chemistry.
Was still blowing things up, but
now I could legally do it you know
and not get a spanking
from my mother.
Played football there O
and 10, three and eight.
We did not do too well my
freshman year or my sophomore year.
But we ended up going to
the play offs my junior
and senior year because we kept on.
We did not give up.
And then I got drafted
to the Detroit Lions.
Detroit, yeah Robin, yeah.
Detroit Lions in the 11th round.
Pulled a hamstring
muscle in training camp.
And then I came back
home and my agent said,
Dallas wants to sign
you for the next season.
So I have from August of 1986
until maybe March of 1987 to figure
out what I am going to do with
my life for those few months.
And this professor at the
University of Virginia said come up,
I want to talk to you about
being a research assistant here.
I am like, but I am going
to play football, man.
You know. Research assistant
and football do not
really you know match.
I go up there.
I start working for him
as a research assistant.
And then when the January
semester started
for material science engineering,
I enrolled knowing I would
be leaving in three months.
And I went to UVA,
started the program.
And then they videotaped
the courses, VHS [laughter].
Old school, right.
So by day I am catching
footballs for America's team.
I mean they cut me too so I do not.
You know, we are in
[inaudible] territory right.
But. And I was playing football
and watching material
science engineering.
And when I pulled my
hamstring for the second time,
it was the end of my
football career.
That is when I went right back
and finished my master's degree
at the University of Virginia.
And so that was my foray in the NFL.
This was the last catch
in a preseason game.
But I had that second
chance for my academics.
And NASA Langley Research Center, I
worked there as a research scientist
with my friend, Rudy King, here.
And we were developing
sensors to help
with the space shuttle
and the space program.
And a friend of mine said, Leland
you would be a great astronaut.
And I am like, yeah right.
He saw something I
did not see in myself.
And he handed me an application.
I looked at it.
I did not fill out.
But another friend of mine filled
the application out and he got in.
And I said to myself, if NASA is
letting knuckleheads like that
in to be astronauts,
maybe I can be one too.
So I applied in the next selection,
which was 1987 for the 1988 class.
And I got in.
And I think about all the people
that have been in the space program.
362 people.
I am in there somewhere.
I had this opportunity.
This small kid from Lynchburg,
Virginia being one of 362 Americans
to have an opportunity
to fly in space.
Now, our class was 25 U.S. out of
25 hundred people, 25 were selected.
And we had six international
astronauts.
Now, can you guys find me
in the picture anywhere?
[Laughter].
In the front row.
On the side.
Let me give you a little
hand there [laughter].
There is Leland in there.
A very diverse group of people.
Navy, Air Force, Marines.
It was an incredible class
of people working together
to help advance our civilization.
And I was in Russia for two
years working with the first crew
that was going to the
International Space Station.
Bill Shepherd, Yuri
Gidzenko and Sergei Krikalev.
And we did all this training.
And I was doing pushups
in the zero G airplane,
which is affectionately
known as the vomit comet.
But we were doing all these things
to get these guys ready
to fly in space.
Expedition one.
The first crew to the Space Station.
And when I came home, it was
time for me to do more training.
This is the Neutral
Buoyancy Laboratory.
It is a six million gallon pool
that we have a submerged space
station and space shuttle.
We go about 30 feet deep in
this pool to do this training.
And you do it in this white
Michelin man looking suit.
There is one little piece of
hardware that goes in the suit
that can be very critical to
your success in the water.
There is a pad called
a Valsalva pad.
It is a Styrofoam block that
you press your nose against.
That if you are the kind
of person that needs
to squeeze your nose to clear.
That allows you to press
your nose against it
in the helmet to clear your ears.
I am the kind of person that
needs to squeeze to clear.
They forgot to put mine in.
We go down about 20 feet
and I tell the test director
to turn the volume
in the headset up.
I hear nothing from
static from that point on.
They are taking me up and down
in the pool trying to
get my ears to clear.
And I do not hear anything.
Let's back up four days
before this thing happened.
My parents were having their
35th wedding anniversary
in Lynchburg, Virginia.
Not far from Pierce Street.
My cousin was in the car with me.
I was dropping them off at a hotel.
And she had her friend
with her named Janette.
Janette said to me, something
is going to happen to you.
No one is going to
know why this happened.
You will be healed of this.
You will fly in space.
This will be your testimony
you share with the world.
And I am like, um [laughter], okay.
I had just come back from
Russia with the first crew.
The next four days later I am going
to start my training
to be a space walker.
And the first people
to get their training
to be space walkers were building
an international space station.
You need space walkers to do that.
She is telling me something
is going to happen to me.
And I listen to people, you know.
I did not shut her down.
Four days later, I
am completely deaf.
They take me out of the pool.
They take my helmet off.
The flight surgeon walks over
to me and he is talking to me.
I think he is joking with me
because he is moving his lips
and I do not hear anything.
He touches my right ear.
He pulls his finger back and
I feel the blood streaming
down the side of my face.
They rush me to the hospital.
And these are the faces
of my surgeons [laughter].
Does not look to optimistic does it?
They went in and operated.
They went in to look around to see
if I had something called a
purulent fistula where the,
I was leaking out of my
ears, on the inner ear,
the oval and circular windows.
And they could not find anything.
Everything was intact.
And about three weeks later,
my hearing slowly came back.
I am still impaired in my left ear,
probably 90 percent of it is gone.
So as an astronaut hearing
is kind of important, right?
And they immediately medically
disqualify me to fly in space.
They said you are never
going to fly in space.
My doctors told me that.
And I was trying to conjure up all
these things, the Little Engine
That Could, I think
I can, I think I can.
Curious George.
All these things.
And when I opened my laptop
up and watched a movie,
I realized when I could not
hear the sound that I was deaf.
My friends consoled me.
The people who looked out for me.
But I was still deaf
in this hospital room.
The head of all of NASA, Daniel
Goldin, came to visit me.
And these legal pads are my way
of communicating with the world.
I could talk, but I would have
to hear what they say
through this writing.
He said I am not going to give
up on you like we did not give
up on the Hubble Space Telescope.
It needed corrective
vision when it was launched.
And he wrote me this long letter
about the Hubble's first image it
took was this eagle's nest nebula
seven thousand light years from
Earth, one light year in length,
the place where stars are born.
He gave me his cell phone number.
He said I will never give up on
you, I will never give up on you.
And then three months
later he was fired
and I am like, oh man [laughter].
That cell phone is no
longer any good, you know.
But you know my hearing did come
back and they were trying to figure
out what to do with me as a you
know hearing impaired astronaut.
So I came up to Washington
D.C. to work in education.
And we started this program
in 2003 called the
Educator Astronaut Program,
where we were going to hire,
let students nominate their
teachers to become astronauts.
And we actually hired three
teachers that have flown in space.
And done space walks and
done all these things.
But I was not going to fly because
I was medically disqualified.
And around that same
time, February 1st, 2003,
we lost Space Shuttle Columbia.
Many of you remember this.
And you know exactly where you were
when it broke up over the Texas sky.
I went to David Brown, who is the
gentleman in the top left corner.
He was a military test pilot.
He was a medical doctor.
He was the doctor that was
actually doing the investigation
on me for my hearing.
And he perished.
We were going to have, do a photo
shoot when he got back home.
He never made it back.
In the bottom left corner,
that is David's father
at Arlington National Cemetery.
We went around the country to
the different memorial services.
We are flying in the NASA
jet, taking off and landing.
And the chief of all the flight
surgeons is sitting beside me
on every mission, on every
launch and landing, taking notes.
When we finished the last memorial
service, he called me in his office
and he said, Leland
I believe in you.
Here is a waiver for
you to fly in space.
When I think about this journey
so far, my friends who came
into that hospital room wrote me
notes saying, you should sue NASA,
write a book and get
paid [laughter].
They hurt you.
And they told you, you are
never going to fly in space.
I believed that that
was not the way to go.
I believe that there is more to
this journey and to not give up
and to have that grit
and perseverance.
And I signed.
I got that waiver.
I went home to Houston
and said look what I got.
And this was the picture I took
when I first got assigned
to my first flight.
They said you can bring your family.
I said well my family
is in Virginia.
But then I thought wait a
minute I have the furry family
and I snuck them in the back gate.
I had about a hundred milk bones
that they, when I was putting
on the orange suit they
were just chomping away.
And I came out and sat down
and they ran over and Jake came
up on my ear and was
nibbling my ear.
Scott was like hey
what are you doing?
And I told the photographer
shoot the picture!
So when Harper Collins said, you
know, what picture are we going
to use for the cover and
I showed him this one
and he said oh that is the picture.
That is the picture.
So that was right before my launch.
Launched in 2008 to the
International Space Station.
Because I had had the hearing loss,
they would not let me
get back in the pool.
So I did robotics instead
of doing space walks.
This is the launch.
Getting to the Space Station.
What it looked like getting there.
We were doing these maneuvers to
take pictures of the underbelly
so we would not have another
Columbia type activity.
And we docked and my job was to
take this Columbus Laboratory,
use the robotic arm to install
it to the Space Station.
Never done it before.
Only in training.
When I got the assignment,
I was in mission control
and there were probably about
20 German flight controllers.
This is the European
Space Agency's Baby.
They have been waiting 10 years
to get this thing installed.
So all these flight
controllers are like,
you know you are installing
our baby, right?
[Laughter].
And so they are high fiving
me and chest bumping me,
you know it is like a joyous moment.
But this one guy as I am walking
out of the room, he turns to me
and he says, Mr. Melvin we
have been waiting 10 years,
do not screw it up.
So I am taking this thing
out of the [inaudible] bay.
We are getting it closer
to the Space Station.
And we are getting it
closer and closer and closer
and the motion just stops.
And in the back of my mind I am
like don't screw it up [laughter].
But one little push, one little pull
on the hand controller
is all it took.
And Dr. Peggy Whitson, who is
coming home tonight at 9 PM,
who will be the longest
person in space, 650 days,
who was the longest U.S. person
in space, was my commander
in my ear saying pull
just a little bit more.
And I think about those figures
again that have been hidden that are
in the forefront inspiring
our young girls to be
and do anything they put their
mind to is such a big part
of what I try to do also.
And Peggy invited us over to
dinner in the Russian segment
and she said you guys bring
the rehydrated vegetables,
we will have the meat [laughter].
We have the meats!
So, we have this meal traveling
at 17 thousand five
hundred miles per hour.
Going around the planet
every 90 minutes.
Seeing a sunrise and a
sunset every 45 minutes.
Doing it with people we
used to fight against.
Russians and Germans.
This is the moment that I went aha.
I thought all the technical
things that we were doing
in space were going
to be my aha moment.
Me saving Europe by installing
their Columbus Laboratory.
It was not that.
It was this moment of breaking bread
with people going around the planet.
It is called the overview affect
or the orbital perspective.
You get this cognitive shift in
your brain that makes you want
to do better when you come home.
It makes you.
15 minutes.
Okay. So, the Detroit and
Dallas of space [laughter].
And had this cognitive
shift one more time.
I think about that is
the outpost that we left
after doing this work
on the Space Station.
So are we ready for questions now?
Or I have 15 minutes before?
15 minutes are left.
So give me three more minutes
and then we will get questions.
You have got to see this view.
This is playing with
your food in space.
But it is also a teaching moment.
This is surface tension.
This is chemistry.
This is physics.
>> Here this is space food.
>> Leland Melvin: I
think about when I talk
to kids the M&M peanut butter
sandwich to you know tortilla.
I think about when I talk
to kids about the future
and what they want to
do with their lives.
I show them this video.
And the ones that do not want to
be astronauts, then they want to be
because you play with
your food in space.
[ Inaudible ]
>> It has to be small enough to be
able to eat in one day, wouldn't it?
Oh a surface one.
Look at that.
Can we see this surface one?
Two surface.
>> Hang on a second
let's get this one.
Oh sorry dude.
>> Ohh.
>> That is going to be [inaudible].
>> I got it.
>> Newton's law [inaudible].
>> It is like croquet or billiards.
>> Are you ready for separation?
>> Separate.
>> Hold on one more.
>> Ah man.
>> Dude.
>> Nice.
>> Oh nice.
>> That is going to be a meal, man.
You got to.
That is a few sips.
>> Oh there you go.
>> Yeah, do not choke on it.
>> Good [inaudible].
>> Go for it L dog.
>> You got it.
Wow almost on the lens.
>> It is a little hotter
than you think.
>> Leland Melvin: I
get to space safely,
install the Columbus
Laboratory and almost choke
on a water bubble and
die [laughter].
My mother saw this video.
She was going to kill me.
Another hand in my development.
But anyway, I want
to take questions now
because we only have a
little bit of time left.
And we can talk about
some of the other slides,
maybe through some of the questions.
So, thank you so much for your time
and attention and your literacy.
[ Applause ]
Any questions.
And if not, we will go
through some more slides.
Okay. Over here.
>> Thank you very much
for your talk.
I was wondering, as someone who is
both an NFL player and a scientist,
in light of all the
recent literature
about brain injury with football.
How has that changed or maybe
not, your support of football
and whether you encourage
and/or discourage young people
from playing the sport?
>> Leland Melvin: That
is a very good question.
I never had a concussion.
I never. I was always able to kind
of like deflect the
blow and get away.
And I did not really spear
as a child, you know.
I am concerned about
what is happening.
I know John Urschel, who played
with the Ravens, is getting his PhD
at MIT and he realized that during
his play he cannot do math the same
way that he was doing before.
I know the NFL is this
money making machine
and all these things and I am torn.
You know, I love football.
I love playing.
I love the competition and all those
things, but we have to think first
of the importance of having
a functioning solid brain
to do other things like
education and so forth.
So I am kind of torn because it was
something that I did for a long time
in my life and I was
passionate about it.
But at the same time, there are more
important things like communicating
with your children and
inspiring the next generation.
And if you cannot do that
because you are impaired
in some way, it is not a good thing.
Okay. Good question.
This one and then come on
up to the mic, right here.
I like your shirt.
>> So for the record.
Oh thanks.
It was intentional.
I definitely had it in mind.
For the record, I am
a diver and I am one
of those people who can just go.
Yep that is all it takes.
>> Leland Melvin: Show
off [laughter].
>> But I. When.
I have always been a really
big, I say space nerd.
But I was in a science class
my freshman year of college
and I was told by a TA that
I ask too many questions
and I would never succeed
in college science.
And I graduated with a
degree in political science
and I taught myself the
physics of space time
so that I can explain
gravitational waves.
But I have a BA in
political science.
How do I get back into.
How does somebody who ends up
out of the sciences or whatever,
get back into that as a career?
Whether that is going back to school
or are there other professional
opportunities within an organization
like NASA for somebody like me.
>> Leland Melvin: So last night
I was, I had listened to Reshma
from Girls that Code, who
has written many books
about you know empowerment
for women coding.
And I think about.
She talked about a young
girl who developed an app
that was helping people take
SAT's and do these things.
Most jobs that you get, you are,
you know your college degree
gets you in that first job.
The second or third or fourth
job is usually the experience
that you have.
So, if you go out and use
your self taught, you know,
knowledge about space and
astronomy and these things,
you know to do something that
you can then empower yourself
to hire the people in
this particular job.
And I think you know it is
really just going for it.
And you know people that write apps
and write codes make
considerable amount of money
with a very small investment
on the front end.
So, it is figuring out how
to do that with the knowledge
that you have that someone is
not going to see a transcript
or a degree in that
particular field.
Because the knowledge
is the power, you know.
It is not the degree.
The parchment paper means nothing.
It is what you have in your head.
So it is demonstrating to
someone that you have those skills
that you can do that particular job.
>> Thanks.
>> Leland Melvin: Yeah.
[ Applause ]
>> So you have played in the NFL,
you have been an astronaut,
you have written a book.
What is your next big dream?
Where do you go from here?
I would like to hear.
>> Leland Melvin: The
next big dream.
I think the biggest dream for me
is to make sure that every kid,
no matter what zip code in
this country, in the world,
knows that they can have the
Curious George moment and knows
that they can have the Little
Engine That Could moment.
And so I am working with a group
of international astronauts
to help everyone see this
perspective from space.
And to have this belief in
themselves that they can do
or be anything they
put their mind to.
Zip codes are the things that
are keeping people from access
to college because of
economic, a number of reasons.
And the visibility of people like
myself and like Rudy and others,
kids in some communities do not even
know that they can do these things.
They do not even know about
the opportunities and so
that is the part to
let Chasing Space
with the young readers edition, let
them do the experiments in the back
of the book and say I am
an engineer like I did
with my mom's chemistry set.
And believe that they
can do it and be it.
That is my mission.
[ Applause ]
>> Leland Melvin: And the
arts are so, such a big.
So I am a STEAM advocate because
we promote STEM and then people
that are doing the arts feel like
they are second class citizens.
But everything we do in science
and technology and engineering
and mathematics is creativity.
And when I was in space, Quincy
Jones said to me, he said,
math and music are the two true
absolutes that use both the right
and left side of the brain.
If you know math, you really
know music and vice versa.
And so we have to tear
down this boundary thing
of you know you can
be one or the other.
You can really be all
of what you want to do
and reinvent yourself
and do anything.
So. Thank you for teaching
by the way.
[Applause].
Yes sir?
>> What was your favorite
thing about going to space?
>> Leland Melvin: The favorite
thing about going to space.
It was not the bathroom,
okay [laughter].
And I have a story about
that later if you want to.
It is really hard to go
to the bathroom in space.
I think the favorite thing
was looking out the window
with my colleagues that I was
work-in with from around the world
and to fly over Lynchburg,
Virginia, my hometown,
and think about my parents and
family having a meal down there.
Five minutes.
Okay. Having a meal down there and
then seven minutes later we are
over Paris and Leo is
looking down thinking
about his family having a meal.
And Yuri is looking off to Russia.
So we are all experiencing seeing
our hometowns from space in a very,
very short period of time.
And then a little bit later you are
back around the planet and if I were
in Virginia, I am not in
Tennessee and I am stepping
across the United States in
this very short period of time.
And then also playing with your food
in space is really
cool too [laughter].
Good question.
Thank you.
Yes sir?
>> So I want to be one of the
next astronauts to go to Mars.
>> Leland Melvin: Okay.
>> And I have gotten into all
GT classes and such and such.
And tried my best with
all that I can do.
What was your motivation?
What kept you going?
>> Leland Melvin: What
kept me going?
I think. I mean, again
getting back to.
Have you read The Little
Engine That Could?
>> Yes, as well as Curious George.
I have been watching those
ever since I was little.
>> Leland Melvin: You have
not read Curious George?
Not yet. I am telling you over.
There is something called
the joy of repetition.
When you have heard
it so many times,
you already believed
that you can do it.
And my motivation was again
having people that believed in my
when I did not believe in myself.
But you have to build
that internal strength
and character and discipline.
That if you fail.
And there is nothing
wrong with failing.
I failed at many things.
It is not that you fail.
It is that you pick
yourself up after the failure
and figure out what was wrong.
We built rockets that failed many
times before we got one right
to get to the Moon.
So keep going.
Just keep going.
Just believe.
And find that person that has your
back and wants you to be successful.
And grab them and say I
want to be on Mars in 20.
What how old are you?
>> I am 12.
So 2030, 2040.
>> Leland Melvin: Okay 2040.
I want to be on Mars in 2040.
Email Elon Musk [laughter].
Seriously, Elon Musk on Instagram.
Say, Elon, hey I want to go to
Mars on the Falcon Heavy baby.
Come one. Help me.
Help me. You know.
I mean reach out to people
that are doing the things
that you want to do.
Reach out to me.
I am on Instagram.
Leland Melvin.
You know and we will
have the discussion.
And if you get to a road block,
we can overcome that road block.
You can get through it.
>> Awesome.
>> Leland Melvin: I cannot wait
to see you up there [applause].
We are out.
Two minutes.
Okay. I am going to get to.
Okay. Go ahead.
>> Hi. I really enjoyed
reading the part of your book
where you were talking
about Nichelle Nichols
and her work with NASA.
I had no idea.
So, I would like to know your
thoughts about women in STEM.
There is a group of STEM
students right here.
One of them is my daughter,
who is starting the STEM
program in three days.
My son is about to
start his third year.
So, I just like your thoughts on it.
>> Leland Melvin: So women in STEAM,
I think is what you said, right?
Women in STEAM?
There is a group called Makers.
Makers.com.
I want you to go to the website.
Send all your girls to the
website and this is a place
that showcases women
doing incredible things.
Peggy Whitson is a Maker woman.
And they see their
path, their journey.
I think about Peggy and her
dream was to be an astronaut.
Not a goal.
It was a dream.
And when Sally Ride became
the first female astronaut,
her dream changed to a goal.
She applied 13 times.
She had a medical condition
where they said you
cannot be an astronaut.
She did the research
and found out that
that is not a problem
for me to go to space.
So 12 times she was denied.
And tonight she comes home
as the first U.S. person
to have 650 days in space.
So, it is the tenacity.
It is the I think I can and believe.
And I say, ladies you
can do anything
that these knucklehead guys can do.
Okay. Seriously.
And I am a Maker man
that supports women.
So, it is just so important
that we do that.
And some of my bosses have been some
of the most incredibly
talented and beautiful.
I mean, I think of
Katherine Johnson.
I was at her birthday party in
West Virginia this past weekend.
She turned 99 years old.
And I think about her
calculations that helped me get
to space on the space shuttle.
Not just John, you know John
Glen, but the rest of our program.
So, girls, ladies do it.
Do it! [Applause].
And do not be shy like
our other friend,
our other NASA friend in here.
Do not be shy.
If a guy tells you that you know
you should be playing dolls,
you should be doing
something else -- show them.
Beat them.
Let the [inaudible] show.
You know, just do not
be intimidated by that.
It is crap.
Yeah. Anyway.
Wrap it up [laughter].
Okay. Well one more question
for the young lady right here.
Okay, go ahead.
>> If you were going to teach
one thing to kids like me
and new young generations of
astronauts, what would it be?
>> Leland Melvin: The one thing
that I would tell you to do is,
I think Mark Twain said it.
The two most important days of
your life are the day you were born
and the day you figure out why.
Study, learn, figure out
why you exist on this planet
and what your purpose is.
To help other people and
advance our civilization.
And once you figure
that out, it is fun.
Alright. Thank you so much.
Have a great day.
Chasing Space.
[Applause].
>> This has been a presentation
of The Library of Congress.
Visit us at log.gov.